(Broad City theme song)
- What's up guys?
My name is Matt FX, Music
Supervisor of Broad City
and here's a recap for
episode five, "Fattest Asses."
First track I'm
featuring in this episode
is the track that runs
under the shopping montage
at the beginning of the episode.
- Let's go shopping.
("Ketamine and Ecstasy" by
Clap Your Hands Say Yeah)
(high five clap)
First one's fine, I think.
- Yeah, your ass
looks incredible.
- The band's called
Clap Your Hands Say Yeah
and the song is song is
called "Ketamine and Ecstacy."
Because who could pick just one?
Next two tracks we're
featuring in the recap
are both tracks
from the party scene
later on in the episode.
First one's from the
slow-mo entrance.
The producer's
name is Whiskers Po
and the track is
called "First Class."
Whiskers Po is a New
Jersey-based producer
making music in every genre
from Jersey Club to deep house.
"First Class" is actually
some of his earlier work
and is technically
juke or footwork
if we were gonna get
specific with the genre.
It's got these two sections
to it, one of which is fast
and speedy, and the other
which is mellow and laid back.
And the mellow and laid back
part was the perfect thing
to run underneath this
slow-mo entrance of the party.
("First Class" by Whiskers Po)
The third and final track in
this recap is another track
from the party scene
of the episode.
The song is called "Yo Sweets,"
and the artist is Najee The 1.
"Yo Sweets" is a
really dope track
that's got a lotta
character and swagger
and this is another
scene in the season
where Abbi's kinda
letting her fun side out.
So in the context
of a party scene
with the hip hop and the
body shots and the fat asses,
I just thought it was
a perfect thing to run.
("Yo Sweets" by Najee The 1)
(crowd cheering)
(high five clap)
Najee The 1 is a rapper
I've had my eye on
for a little while now.
He deserves all the success
that's coming to him.
"Yo Sweets" is a
really dope track
and I was really happy to be
able to include it in the show.
Hope you enjoyed this episode,
this is one of my favorite
episodes in the season so far.
Keep your asses fat and
I'll see you next week.